الى اا بدر الزير همم امام ستاد لوزيل
والمزيد من ردود الفعل الخاصه بالجماهير
السعوديه التي يكيد تحتفل بهذا الفوز
التاريخي
دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه
انا شو بقول
بنبدا
ارجنتين نجوم لكن القمر من هو السعوديه
قام القمر معي مالي
[تصفيق]
ومالي ومالي
السعوديه ترجع في الشوط الثاني
بسيطه التسلل في الشوط الاول والشوط
الثاني يلعبوا على المرتدات والحمد لله
توفينها اللهم لك الحمد
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
99 سيدات طبقنا عليهم تكتيك من هرفي ريناد
صراحه المدرب يعني شغل شهر كامل اليوم
بيننا اياه النوع انا بالمجموعه حتى لو
اقابل مين شكرا للمدرب شكرا ل اللعيبه
اللي طبقوا التكتيك الله يعطيهم العافيه
جينا من كل مدينه والله وفرحونا ما قصروا
الله يعطيكم العافيه